hopefully give you food for thought but
if it's like super
fascinating and interesting then you're
warmly invited to stay along for the
second half when we're going to get the
really exciting stuff
and we're beyond like the introductory
regular seminar
during the second hour i think daniella
will open up the hood a bit and
you know spill her own deepest secrets
about this work and how it works and
maybe talk a bit about future challenges
or what what not
so there's this is to say that there
will be like a first hour regular talk
and then a second hour
more technical in-depth continuation to
also maybe inspire us
uh regarding topics to talk about during
the summer
semesters so without further ado daniela
the floor is yours
so thank you jakobs and thank you for
having me here
yeah as you said today i'm going to talk
about
combining sat and computer algebra for
circuit verification
but let me start my talk uh with the
following question
namely what is four million one hundred
ninety five thousand eight hundred
thirty five
divided by three million one hundred
forty five thousand
seven hundred twenty seven i mean
obviously i can't solve this in my head
and i'm too lazy to do that on paper
so let's use a calculator for to solve
this equation
and type in the first number divided by
the second number
and then we get the result obviously we
could also use
something like excel for that or
also a computer algebra system if you
preferred it
but nevertheless we see that in each
of these tools uh we get the same result
namely that the solution is 1.3338
so so far so good and now
i want to take you back in time so
now let's travel back a little more than
26 years ago
to the 21st 4th of october
1994. and on this day
so the reason why i chose this day is
because on this day thomas nicely is
going to contact
intel about something strange that he
observed
while doing uh calculus calculations
more precisely
divisions on his computer and i want to
show you now
what he observed so hold on tight and
let's go
back in time so
there we are now in 1994 i mean
obviously it's kind of a strange version
because apparently we already have
windows 95 and we can use a flat screen
with an hdmi input
but never mind and now let's do our
calculation here
so i hope this video shows for you
let's open here our calculator
and then do the exact same
calculation as i just did with you
uh on my regular
laptop and what we see here right now is
that the solution is actually different
so instead of the 1.3338
which we got previously uh we now get a
different result namely
1.3337
and that's exactly what uh thomas
observed that sometimes he got indirect
incorrect results of a division
and after making sure that it's not was
not the fault that is his side
and it was also not a software bug but
in
indeed it was a hardware error he
reported this issue to intel and this
specific error became well known as
the pentium bug which
affected early intel processors so
in the youtube video i just showed you
the computer uses
such an uh process of type
sx923 and when we open
for example the cpu work then we see
here on the notes
that this processor has indeed
the uh well-known f div
bug and so this bug affected the
floating point
unit in the early end processors and had
the effect
that it as we just saw that this
processor
might return incorrect results for
division
and back then this led to costs of about
500 million
dollars for intel and when we think of
how much computers and processes are
used nowadays
i'm pretty sure that if such as such a
bug would happen today this would mean
serious
troubles for hardware companies so these
companies really want to make sure
that their hardware is correct
however even today like more than 25
years later
verification of arithmetic circuit is
still
considered to be hard in practice and
requires
a lot of manual effort to do so
and especially among the arithmetic
circuits proving the correctness of
gate level into the integer multiplier
circuits is
considered to be a challenge
and that's exactly what we will consider
now in this talk namely the verification
of such gate level integer multiplier
circuits
so we all know how to multiply on paper
and here we have for example the
binary encoding of three times three
and we now want to calculate the product
so in the beginning we build the partial
product
which is rather easy here because it's
all ones and then we start
with the last column and uh
sum up the partial products so the last
column is only one
entry so we have a one without the carry
then we sum up two ones which gives us
output zero and the carry
of one then we again sum up two ones
with output theory
zero and a carrier of one so we now
calculated that three times three is
equal to nine
uh yes and
in computers this multiplication
is executed using these gate level
circuits
so here on the right you see a two bit
multiplier
um this circuit so an arithmetic circuit
consists of a set of logical
gates these are these guys here that are
connected
uh by wires and then arithmetic circuit
receives then here uh
the binary inputs and on top
and according to the gates
the input signals are then processed
through the circuit
until we receive here the output at the
bottom
so this circuit has two kind of gates
namely an and gate
and an xor gate the and gate models
logical conjunction where the output is
one
if and only if both inputs are one
and for the exaggerate it's the case
that
the output often execute this one if and
only if
both inputs are different from each
other
and then we see let's see what this
circuit here
computes so we start here with the first
end gate
it receives two ones as input we take a
look at the truth table and we see the
output has to be one
similar for all the other end gates in
the first row
then we have now here an exo gate
which reads two ones so we take again
and look at the truth table
we see two ones gives us the output zero
then we continue here with the end gate
again with two ones
so the output is also one and then again
we have an
extra gate with two ones and finally
also an end gate with two ones
so we see here that also this this
multiplier
computer that's three times three is
equal to the output line
so we can now ask the question is the
circuit correct
and let us compare now the circuit
what the circuit computed to what we
compared on the paper
since it's both time the same output we
can actually
kind of conclude so yes the circuit
seems correct to us because we now have
tested it and
it looks pretty good
another question is is the circuit
really correct
and with really correct
um i mean that when you have given a
gate level multiplier for a fixed input
bit width
the question is whether for all possible
combinations of the inputs
is the output bit vector always equal to
the product
of the input bit vectors so in the
following we will always denote
the two input bit vectors with a
and b the output will be labeled with s
and then we have the internal gates that
are labeled with a t
and yeah we now want to
derive whether no matter what a plucky
in here at the
at the top um the output down here
is always the product of the input
so how can we do that i mean the first
idea
would not be simply okay let's test all
possible combinations
but already here for these two
bit multipliers we already need
16 test cases so here on the left you
see all these possible
combinations and i guess you can imagine
that this
scale is pretty bad if we increased a
bit with
so uh as you see here so for example if
the input bit
is 64 we are talking already uh
about this really huge number so there's
no way
that we can test all possible
combinations in a reasonable amount of
time
and this is now where formal
verification comes into the game
because we now want to translate the
system and the specification
in a mathematical model and then let the
automated decision process
decide on the correctness of the circuit
and in the past several formal
verification techniques have been used
for
arithmetic circuit verification so
for example sat solving and a large
set of multiplier benchmarks
were sent to the sub competition in the
year 2016.
however the results uh showed
that actually satso was performed pretty
bad
on checking the equivalence of
multipliers
and this somehow led to the conjecture
that such always need an exponential
runtime on
these benchmarks
another technique uh
is based on decision diagrams so more
precisely on
binary moment diagrams and this was
actually the first
technique uh which was able to detect at
the pentium bug
but here the problem is that it cannot
be applied fully automatically
because you need to build the decision
diagrams in a certain order
to guarantee that the size of the
decision diagrams
does not explode so you need to manually
sort a
certain way how the decision diagram is
built
another possibility would be the use of
theory improving and that is actually
what is used
uh in industries
uh but also here the problem is that it
requires
a lot of manual effort last year there
has been made some progress in this
theorems over acl2
however there uh you need to have some
structural knowledge
of the multiplier so also here you can
not directly plug in
multipliers purely on the gate level
the currently most successful uh
verification approach for the skate
level multipliers is actually based
on computer algebra and it started with
these two papers which came out in 2015
and 2016.
and in the algebraic approach we use a
polynomial uh
encoding to model the circuit
and this approach now also works
fully automatically for non-trivial
multiplier designs
yeah so the basic idea
of the algebraic approach is
that we translate the multiplier into a
set of polynomials
then we also have the specification
as a polynomial and we want to show
whether the specification polynomial is
implied
by the polynomials that are induced by
the circuit which actually means
that we want to show that the
specification has
polynomial has the same roots than the
same
than the circuit polynomials and this
algebraically means
that what we want to solve is actually
the ideal membership problem
for the specification
and now i want to go into the details of
each of these parts of the algebraic
approach
and i want to start now
with the specification
so yeah here you see the specification
polynomial uh when we model
multiplication of
unsigned integers and it's actually
encoding that the
output bit vectors written down here as
a weighted sum
is equal to the product of the input
vectors and together with the
specification
because we are talking over polynomials
we
also need to fix the
polynomial ring and
we choose the polynomial ring here
over the integers because we are
actually so we want to model
integer multiple multiplication so this
seems
to be the natural choice
so a comment here so uh
also the each of the variables
represents a boolean variable variable
the word level specification
is defined over the integers
if we want to model
signed integers then the specification
is actually the same
but we need to take into account that
the most significant bit
represents the sign so that's why we
have here
now a negative weight
yeah in the following
uh because now our left side is always
equal to zero
i remove now this equal to zero
so from now on i will only represent uh
polynomials
uh like this without writing this equal
to zero on the left or right side
yeah and i mean i just
argued why we
choose here the polynomial ring over the
integers
but actually we make it easier for us
because the integers are the ring
polynomial ring of the integers
is a subset of the polynomial ring over
the quotient
or the rationals
and thus we choose now
the polynomial ring over the rationals
because the rationales are a field the
integers are not
and we want to work in a polynomial ring
over a field because this makes things
easier for us and i will explain later
in the talk why this is
important for us
so we now have our specification
polynomial
we have our polynomial domain so
we can now move on to
the second part namely how do we get
actually from the multiplier circuits
to the set or to its polynomial encoding
and there we again take a look at the
truth tables
of the gates and
we encode now each gate by a
corresponding
polynomial so for example here for this
end gate
we get with inputs f and g
and output y we get the polynomial
minus y plus f times t
and if we plug in here another possible
combinations
we see that uh y is one
if and only if f and g are one
otherwise y is zero if either f or
g is zero and it's in a similar style
we find uh the polynomial encoding of
the exergate so it looks a little bit
more uh
complex than the one for the n gate but
it's actually
found in a similar way and because we
are working
uh in a polynomial ring over the
rationals
we have here now this minus
this monomial now with coefficient minus
2.
yeah and then we traverse through
the circuit and for each gate in the
circuit we
write down the corresponding polynomial
equation
and we start here by the outputs
and here we have the first the end gate
with
inputs g1 and g4 and since it's an and
gate
we get here this polynomial equation
and then we move through the circuit and
do this for every gate in the circuit
and we sort the polynomials or
especially the terms in a specific way
namely since we started here at the
outputs and traversed up to inputs
we can sort the polynomials in such a
way
that always the output variable is
larger than the input variables of the
gate
and by that we get this shape that
always the first
term in the polynomial so the leading
term consists
only of the output variable of
the gate and this property will also be
important
later on yeah and after we've
defined all the gate polynomials we
need to take now we need to model
that the input is of the boolean domain
and we do this by adding so-called
boolean
value constraints which simply encode
that so this equation is equal to 0
if and only if a1 is either 0 or
a1 is 1. so here we model that
these variables can only take the values
zero or one
and so these are not in the brilliant
value constraints in
an expanded form
yeah and
so we have now this encoding but
actually we can find many more
such relations in
the gate in the circuit so not only do
we have
uh here this
our gate constraints and the boolean
value constraints for the inputs
but in fact it also holds that the
internal variables are all of the
boolean domain
or we can define find other constraints
which always are equal to 0 namely for
example
it is x or n constraints which says
that the output of an and gate and an
exo gate
which both receive the same inputs
can never be both a one at the same time
and we call all these circuit relations
the polynomial circuit constraints
and they have the following definition
so a polynomial
is such a circuit constraint
if for all possible inputs
so for all um yeah
combinations of the boolean variables on
the inputs
and the resulting values that are
computed by the circuit
for uh the g1 to gk and the outputs
the substitution of these values in the
polynomials
gives always gives the value 0.
and we collect now all these polynomial
circuit constraints
in a set which we denote here by ifc
so this set contains then all the
relations
that hold in the circuit c
and mathematically this set
now generates or is an ideal
and ideal is a set
of polynomials that is closed under
addition so whenever we take
two elements from an ideal the sum
is also contained in the ideal and
it's closed on the multiplication by any
polynomial from the polynomial ring
so when we take a polynomial from the
ideal
we can multiply it by any other
polynomial from the ring then the
product also needs
is contained in the idea so that's the
definition
of an idea
and we are now particularly interested
in
one such circuit relation namely in the
relation between the
outputs and the inputs of the
circuit so
we say that a circuit is called the
multiplier
if the specification which is the
relation between the outputs and the
inputs
is now contained in the ideal
and you see this brings us now down here
what that what we want to solve is in
fact
the ideal membership problem so we want
to show whether the specification
is contained in the ideal
that contains all the circuit relations
yeah and for that
we actually need one another definition
namely the
basis of an ideal so a set of
polynomials
is called the basis of an ideal if
uh all polynomials that are
all elements from an ideal can be
represented
as a linear combination of uh the basis
elements
and if that's the case then we also say
that the ideal i
is generated by this given set
of polynomials g
and when we have given an arbitrary
basis key of the ideal it is not obvious
how to decide the ideal membership
problem what we in fact need
is a bases with
certain structural properties and these
bases are called
grimner bases
so the exact definition of the gravina
basis
is not important to us but what is
important
is that it offers a decision procedure
for the ideal membership problem
in a polynomial ring over a field
and that's why it was so important for
us that we choose
the rationals and not the integers in
the beginning because now we can use
the theory of grignard basis
to answer the ideal membership problem
then it holds that every ideal has a
finite gravity basis
and when we have given an arbitrary
basis of an ideal
then we are able to compute the gryphon
basis
and so this sounds now
pretty good for us so we now
know how to solve the ideal membership
problem but
there comes the big but so computing
equivalent basis over the rationales and
deciding the ideal membership is
actually
known to be in x x place complete
so it's um it's a pretty expensive uh to
do it that way
however since we chose such
a specific ordering of the polynomials
we can actually use a shortcut
for the gribner basis computation
but first we need uh to deal with the
second problem
so i told you that from
an arbitrary basis we can compute the
grimnar basis
but the fact is for our ideal ifc
we do not know any bases so we only know
that it's the big set which contains all
the circuit relations
however we can deduce some of
some elements of the eyes because we
always know that the gate polynomials
and the boolean value constraints are
contained in this ideal
so let us now generate a second ideal
in which we call j of c and this is not
ideal that this
really generated only by the gate
polynomials and the boolean value
constraints
and because we now choose this uh
specific term ordering namely that the
output variable of a gate is always
greater than
the input variables
the following can be shown for k of c
namely that in fact the gate polynomials
and the boolean value constraints
are already equivalent basis for the
second idea
so this means we do not have to compute
the grammar basis
but in fact by choosing this term
ordering
we have already written down a grammar
basis
and the proof idea behind this is that
we repeatedly
apply a book product criterion which
um allows us to skip uh
parts in the computation of the grimner
basis
so in fact in our case we do not have to
do any
um computation
so now we have our two ideals so we have
now the ideal ifc for which we want to
derive the deal membership
and we have now our second ideal jfc for
which
we already have um agronomy basis
and we can actually show
the following so for all our cyclic
circuits
we have infected those two ideas
are the same which
brings down to soundness and
completeness of
the method
yeah and since we now have a grammar
basis for
our ideal ifc we can apply the following
verification algorithm
namely that we reduce the specification
by the gate constraints and boolean
value constraints
until no further reduction is possible
then the circuit is a multiplier if and
only if
the remainder is 0. so for the reduction
we use some kind of polynomial division
and i now want to show this to you on
our
small two bit multiplier
so here on the left we have uh all the
gate constraints
and the boolean value constraints and
here on the right we have the
specification
and yeah so let's now reduce the
specification here by the first
polynomial so it is minus s3 plus
g1 g4 and since we have this
special uh
uh shape of the polynomials where
all the leading terms consist only of
one variable
and the leading coefficient is -1
in our setting the polynomial division
actually
boils down to replacing here always this
the variable of the leading term so in
this case the s3
by the complete tail of the polynomial
so in this case now instead of s3 we get
now g1
times g4 in the second step
we do this now for here for this
s 2 and replace the s2
now here by the complete term uh tail of
this
polynomial and what you see
here too is now that
in the second step we introduced here
this monomial
8 times g1 times g4
which now in the second step uh cancels
again so it's sometimes
or actually it quite frequently happens
that we introduce
monomials during the reduction
which then will get cancelled in
later steps and
these uh monomials which we introduced
in
uh during some uh reduction and
they only get cancelled later they are
actually a big
problem for us in the verification
step because sometimes we ignore
sometimes we get quite
uh quite a lot of them and this slows
down
the verification steps significantly
and i will show you a graphic for that
in in
in a second but now let's continue here
our verification steps so in the next
uh step we re reduce
here by uh the g4 and get the
g2 g3 and so on and so forth
and we continue until we now got our
final remainder zero
so here we now see that
the multiplier i showed you in the
beginning is indeed a correct
two-bit multiplier
what happens now if uh
we introduce an error so
let us take here for example the the
input
of the skate g3 which goes here to the
a1 and move it
to read the a0 instead so then we also
get here now
a different gate constraint
and in the verificational steps now the
following happens
so the beginning is the same until we
are now here
at this step where we introduce now
the wrong the error
and then we are left
at the end with a remainder which is
unequal to zero
so at this point we do not have any
polynomial
left on the on the left side which can
be used
to reduce uh here this
final remainder so we know now
that the circuit is incorrect
and from this remainder we can
also derive counter examples so concrete
[Music]
assignments for the inputs where we see
that the circuit
computes a wrong result
so for doing that we choose
an assignment of the inputs in
such that this polynomial evaluates to
something
which is unequal to zero
and so let's for example set a zero and
b
0 both to 1 and a 1 and b
1 both to zero
then we get the effect that the first
monomial
evaluates to zero and the second
evaluates to one
so we get uh two which is unequal to
zero
for this assignment we actually would
uh expect the circuit to compute that
one
times one is equal to one but
when we plug the input
in here and then compute the signals
then we actually see
that in that case the circuit computes 1
times 1 is equal to 3
so we have now here
one specific counter example for which
we see
that the circuit is indeed not correct
yeah so as i already hinted
uh with these green boxes during the
verification algorithm
is that if we would uh apply
this algorithm just as it is like like
that that we reduce the specification
by the elements of the gate so by the
gate constraints and the green value
constraints
uh then this has the effect that uh
for larger multipliers the number of the
monomials in the intermediate reduction
results increases drastically
and for our setting this had the effect
that even we could not even
verify an 8-bit multiplier within
20 minutes and
in related work the actually did
some experiments on the
monomial size after
each substitution steps and so they
choose
a simple multiplier architecture this is
always here
the blue line and uh some non-trivial
multiplier architecture this is here the
red line
and we see uh
so they did this for four bit eight bit
and 16 bit
uh multipliers and we see for the simple
multipliers
kind of the monomial size stays
quite constant before it reduces to zero
finally
but for non-trivial multipliers we see
here this big
up and downs especially a big up in the
beginning
before it then drops to something uh
constant
and then reducing to zero and here for a
16-bit
uh d reached over more than 10 million
monomials in
uh such uh was in in one of the
intermediate
uh results of the reduction also
there it's timed out for them
so that's why we cannot use this uh
reduction algorithm like out of the box
and that's where
we and also the other groups are now
working on to
find ways to overcome this issue of the
large of increase of
the monomers and i now want to show you
my approach to overcome this issue
so the first idea
which we are using is that instead of
taking the complete uh specification
and doing this uh reduction
steps we instead do an incremental
verification
algorithm where we cut
the multiplier into slices and then
verify
incrementally verify the correctness of
each
slice and the idea is basically taken
from how we do the multiplication
um on paper because also there we first
built the partial products and then we
do this column wise uh
summing up so where we take the partial
products of
each slice
add add it to the incoming carries then
write down the sum bit
and send carries to the next slice
and that's exactly how this algorithm
works so we cut here
the multiplier in such a way that each
slice contains
only one output bit and then we start at
the most significant
[Music]
output and yeah verify
the correctness of these slides until we
re i hear it the least significant uh
output bit and there
we check whether uh
the final remainder is zero
yeah so our input format is actually not
this
uh gate level circuit as you see here on
the left
instead we use uh and inverter graphs
um yes in any vertograph
each of the nodes represents logical
conjunction
and the marking on the input edge
represents
the negation of the input signal
so this aig here on the right
is uh this is the aig
encoding of this two-bit multipliers
which we
used now throughout the talk so
for example here this and gate which
reads
uh b b0 and
a 0 as input and s 0 output
is represented by this node
which gets here input a 0 b 0 and has
output is
0 2. yeah and for the xo gates we need
a couple of more of the and gates
but the reason why we're using it it's
uh because it's very easy
uh to deal with and it's actually a
standard format
for uh to represent hardware uh
circuits so just to double check
danielle so an and inverter graph that's
just what we theoreticians would call a
boolean circuit but the gates are and
and not
is that correct kind of except you put
the knots on the wires
i guess yes we put so here that the
knots are on the wires
okay
what's the difference between the
squares and the circles or the ovals
so could you say again uh do the
these uh squares are correspond to and
gates and ovals correspond to
no sorry so these squares here like this
two four
six and eight uh they represent the
inputs again
okay and the circles are all and gates
execute these are all so the ovals these
are all ends and
the filled dots they represent the
negation and the triangles are the
labels for
for the inputs and the outputs
yeah so this was now the erg
for the 2-bit multiplier let's now
increase
the size so here you see an erg for a
4-bit multiplier
and when we take a closer look
we can identify certain
substructures uh in the aig
namely this uh orange
that's the orange marked ones they
define a full adder
then we have here in half adder this is
how we present
an exergate now in an aig and then we
also have here
several nodes which only have
one outgoing edge
and what we now want to do in a
pre-processing step
is uh because you see here for example
in
in the half adder the internal nodes so
so these two
they are only used internally
so what we now want to do here is
we want to eliminate this nodes
and represent uh the output so
this one and this node here directly in
the input uh of the half header
and you can also see here the same for
the full edit that we also have here
quite a lot of internal uh
nodes that are not connected to anywhere
outside this full adder
only here the some output bit and here
the carry output
of the full letter are then used in
other structures but the internal
ones the are really only used in this
full letter
so that's why we want to eliminate them
first before we do the specification
reduction
because this helps us to reduce
not only the number of reduction steps
of the specification
but in fact we also get a simpler
representation
of degrees
and so for variable elimination
uh we used the elimination theory of
burglar bases
and in our first attempt
we really identified
syntactically the sub-circuits in the
eit's and then eliminated the
internal variables so we had our schemes
for
detecting the full letters the half
adders the xors
and then also for eliminating the nodes
with the single dependency
but we modified this elimination
scheme so
because the reason if you do syntactic
pattern matching
then also small changes already in the
pattern
um let's
had the effect that we we could not
detect the patterns anymore and could
not apply
the full the rewriting steps anymore
so what we now do instead is uh we have
some kind of repeated elimination of
variables with a single dependency
this does not rely on specific patterns
anymore
and in fact it also subsumes um all the
others
rewriting schemes where we really
identify
the sub-circuits
yeah and as i said for that we use the
elimination
theory of groomer bases so
if we want to eliminate a variable in a
grammar basis
we first need to fix an elimination
order and for that
we uh split our variables into do
disjoint sets namely in the one
variables we want to keep
which are now written here and by y and
then the ones which we want to eliminate
which now written here as
the set and in an elimination order we
now need to order this the terms in
structural way
that all terms that contain variables
which
shall be eliminated are larger than all
the terms
uh which do not contain these
variables and then the elimination
idea is simply defined as the
intersection
over the polynomial's ring with the
variables
which we want to keep
and the eliminations theorem of
brightness bases
now tells us how we could
compute agreement basis for the
elimination ideal because
obviously again we want to have a
agreement basis for our method
uh to work and
so the eliminations theorem says that we
need to compute
a grammar basis for with respect to
the elimination order and then we
simply kick out all the very all the
polynomials
that contain variables which shall be
eliminated
and then we have found a grammar basis
for the elimination ideal
however as you remember
i said that computing the program basis
and then answering
the ideal membership is x space complete
so
this does not sound too promising
but again we can here make use of our
special shape of the polynomials
namely that all the leading terms
consist of only
one variable and all the variables are
also different from each other because
for each gate
we only define one polynomial so all our
leading terms are
unique and let's do the following
examples so i've written down here now
an idea with the following ordering so
that's
uh how do these polynomials are ordered
now where
always larger x larger than y and larger
than
a and b and let us now assume that from
this
ideal we want to eliminate
y because we notice that y is an
internal variable for us so let's
get rid of this
and what we do now is that
we compute the remainder
of the polynomial with leading term o
and reduce it by the polynomial with
leading term y
this has defected actually all the y's
in this polynomial are replaced by the
tail
so in this case a b
and then we add this polynomial to the
gryphon basis and we are always allowed
to add uh vary polynomials to gravity
bases
that were derived uh doing uh polynomial
operations
and then because we have two very two
polynomials with the same leading term
we can
[Music]
eliminate one of the polynomials
because so this is also uh from
the theory of grammar basis that when
you have two polynomials with the same
leading terms you're always allowed
to kick one out so obviously we will
kick
the bond uh we choose the polynomial
which contains the y
and remove it from our algorithmic basis
so at this point we are now left with
these three
polynomials and let's now see what
happens when we now choose the variable
ordering
such that y is the largest element
then we see that actually nothing
changes because
y only occurs in one polynomial where it
is already the leading term so it cannot
move any further in front
and then we do the intersection so we
simply kick it out
and that's how we get the
gravina bases for the variable
elimination
so you see in in fact of doing this
regular basis computation
for different variable ordering actually
in fact what we do
is we replace all occurrences
of the variable which we want to
eliminate by the corresponding tail of
the polynomial
and then delete all the variables all
polynomials
that contain the variable which we want
to
eliminate yeah
and all of what i just said can be
written down in these two beautiful
theorems
but i'm not going into detail of them
so with these two techniques so the the
um incremental verification algorithm
and with doing the variable elimination
uh
so prior to the incremental
specification reduction
we could already verify
simple multiplier architectures
pretty effectively so in this actu
you see such a simple
so this has now an input bit width of
eight
and this multiplier uses uh
an area accumulation to add up the
partial product so this is
here kind of this block down here where
uh full adders are arranged now in a
kind of gridless structure
to sum up the partial products and then
here on top we have a ripple carry adder
which contains a sequence consists of a
sequence of
full adders which are used to compute
the final output of the circuit
so this multiplier has a very regular
structure
but it's not very uh efficient because
at first we need to wait
uh for the signals uh to be
accumulated and then we need especially
here
need to wait for the singers to be
ripped
through the whole adder until we get
here
our final output signal
so that's why in in practice there are
different
multiplier architectures which are way
more efficient
so for example this one here where
instead of an area accumulator we use
now a volustry accumulator which reduces
now
the delay of the accumulation step
and then instead of a ripple carry adder
uh
on the output we now have here
a carry look ahead adder on the top and
in the carry look ahead other
instead of waiting for the carry to be
ripped through
now the carries uh are computed
at the same time then all the the output
bits
the accumulation step is uh still
easy to verify using computational
because again it consists of the full
and half adders that are arranged in a
different pattern
but what's really hard to verify
is here this carry look ahead on top
and for the reason i first want to zoom
in a little bit into the carry look at a
header
and then let's color some gates
because what you see here is that here
this
single orange note on top
is computed using here the sequence
of gates which only have um
which all of them have only one single
output
so there is no cancellation happening
so in during reduction we need to remove
all this single nodes to represent
uh here this output bit
and in fact this sequence um
compute is represents
a sequence of or gates and these orbits
is
what makes the uh sequence of the orchid
makes it so hard
for computer algebra
and the reason is the polynomial
representation
of the orchids so here i have now a
sequence of
three or gates and when we see now
that we want to
represent here the output of the last
or gate in terms of all the inputs we
need
to remove these two variables so that
o1 and the o2 and if we do this in this
step
we get now a polynomial here with
15 monomials so already for
uh three orchids we
derive a polynomial with 15 monomials
and in the fact in the example which i
showed you before we already have a
sequence of uh
eight or gates so you can see uh
the representation of the sequence of
orbits uh
grows uh exponentially so it's uh really
bad for us for the computer algebra
approach
however we notice
that there's a question yeah so maybe
i'm i'm
jumping ahead i guess but like
so am i correct that if you look at this
expression that you had on the previous
slide it would have been
really nice to have formal variables for
negated literals
so then i would have written it
something like the output is 1 minus
times of the negated inputs
um
[Music]
yeah yeah so here it could definitely
work
that that for
these or gates we can
uh yeah if we
choose here now now variables for the
negation
then i think this should be
representable with only one
monomial i can do
i can do two i think i do like one one
minus the product of the negations
because if they're all false then we're
screwed
but uh
but otherwise we know that everything is
true but then the problem is that this
of course
screws up like you know and you have to
throw them into like where do they end
up in the garden basis ordering as
massimo is already noting in the chat
and this is like yes
but if we somehow didn't have to worry
about this you know must
be a bit more visionary great yeah
these are the and i'm mentioning this
because these are the twin variables
that theoreticians sometimes throw in
uh when they do these algebraic proof
systems
yeah because yes as you pointed out so i
think that's that's the
danger because they are like on the same
level than
than the variable like the negation and
the positive variable
and sometimes you want to use them
sometimes you don't and then you
need to tell the grammar basis algorithm
really especially
where to use them and where to not use
them and please don't throw them away
so massimo is writing this is
essentially like writing the orders in
the gated end
of negation yes
so the fast answer is yes for but i need
to think about it lagging more more
a little bit more about that
um
so but let me continue here so what
we observed because
uh so two years ago in 2019
we noticed that actually
checking the equivalence of other
circuits is
quite easy for sat solvers
and this led to
the following idea that namely we
identify
where there is the border between the
accumulation step and the final stage
error
so the last error in the multiplier
then we make a cut here
and we replace the final stage editor by
the simple ripple carry adder which
we can verify using computer algebra
and for the
correctness of the error substitution we
choose satsarin to check the equivalence
of the two adders
and for the rewritten multiplier we then
use the computer algebra approach
so yeah so for uh
checking the equivalence of the editors
we
take both headers then generate a bit
level multipliers to translate
the whole aig into the cnf the cnf
is given to uh the sat solver and to
show the correctness
the sat server then needs to return uh
unsub
for us and as i said for
the
rewritten multiplier we use
uh the computer algebra approach
yeah in the beginning of our work we
used existing computer i suppress system
for doing that because i mean they had
all the algorithms
implemented so we choose specifically
mathematical
and singular to to
for circuit verification uh yep these
tools have
a lot of algorithmic power for example
mathematica has more than five thousand
billion functions
and all these scrivener basis libraries
they were easy to use
but however they are designed for
general purposes and i mean our
polynomials they really have this
specific
shape and these computer architectural
systems
we could not really make i mean we had
to add all the special constraints
uh to tell them about the shape of our
polynomials so we then decided to
implement our own reduction
engine and that we are already now at
version two which is going
to appear attackers in a couple of
months
and amoled 2
is implemented in c plus plus contains
about 6 000 lines of code
and it automatically applies the adder
substitution
and the circuit verification
and all the polynomial algorithms which
are implemented there
are designed to make use of the
properties
of the polynomial so that the leading
terms are all
the single variables and so on and what
we also do
is that we apply on the fly reduction of
the boolean value constraints
so in fact we always calculate that x
times x
is equal to x and not 2x squared
yeah and on here on the right you see
how we a typical tool flow for
amoled so at first we give it the input
a actually then the error substitution
happens
where amulet outputs the cnf encoding
which can
we can give to a subsolver for example a
key set
to tell us whether the replacement of
the final stage data is correct
and the rewritten multiplier
is again an eig which is then given
again
to to our tool amoled and where then the
verification step happens
and now i want to make a quick demo
of amulet so
what we choose here now is the input
is now a multiplier with input bit with
512 so rather a large example
and we directly call amulet with uh in
the verification mode because i know
that the final stage editor of this
particular benchmark
is already a simple uh ripple carry
adder
and we add here uh
the minus v2 flag so that we see some
statistics yeah in the beginning uh
some some some statistics are printed so
what we can see here is that this
particular
instance consists of more than 2 million
aig nodes and then the
allocation steps are happening
after that the pre-processing steps are
happening
so we see here uh how many
variables are for example uh
we're eliminated during uh
from from internal x-circuits so we see
this
like more than uh half a million of
these nodes
uh were eliminated and
after pre-processing is finished
um we start producing now the
as we do know that the slice wise
reduction
and uh we always print now the result
after
uh the reduction by one slice
is finished so this is now the
intermediate uh polynomial after
reducing by the
first uh slice and what you see here is
that we actually
really deal with quite large
coefficients in this polynomials
because we really need to encode a 2 to
the power 1023
yeah and when we wait so the polynomials
get
larger and larger with the slices and we
can even
zoom out a little bit they will still
get larger and now feel
the complete display and
but when we wait long enough they will
get small again
until we reached here now slice zero
so the last slice where it says that the
remainder is zero
so the search i think your screen at
least on my side your screen is not i
still have sliced
1021 okay
then maybe i quit sharing a star again
maybe this helps
did this help for you
yes good things are shrinking a lot
and i'm i can now see slide zero
yes perfect so then the magic happened
for you
that yeah the slice zero so the final
remainder is zero and indeed we get the
message that
uh the multiplier is correct and
so verifying this 512 mid
bit multipliers now only took us a 43
seconds
so remember in the beginning i told you
like with with our initial approach we
could not even verify
8-bit multiplier within 20 minutes and
now we can verify 512
bit multiplier within as a with
in 43 seconds so that's
that's pretty cool
oops so yes
but now the question is is the circuit
really really correct
so can you trust my implementation or is
even the verification process
itself correct
and so
what we want to do is now we want to
validate the result
of the verification process so we want
to
generate uh machine checkable proofs
that
can then be checked by independent proof
checkers in order
to increase the trust in the
verification
result um
yeah so what we now
want to do is we want to monitor the
reduction
the steps in the reduction algorithm and
i won't go too much into detail about
here about this proof vlogging because
this was actually my
plan to present
like after the break so where i want to
go more into detail about
this method but what we do here
during proof logging is that we write
down a sequence of
multiplication and addition steps which
help
to us to uh
verify or to validate the ideal
membership of the specification
and here you can see kind of the the
history of our proof
um system so this was
like uh how we defined it in 2018
and from then on we worked a little bit
on as we worked on
deriving uh shorter and more concise uh
proofs so this is how a
short part of how these proof
certificates look now for
uh our examples or like uh
our benchmarks yeah and for
checking these proofs we implemented uh
uh proof checkers so the first one is
pectrim uh
which worked on our initial proof uh
um proof system
so it supports only the the older pack
formats
and our most recent one is here pictek
which supports now the new calculus
and but it's also backward compatible to
the older back performance
and as i said after the break i will go
into more detail
about uh the proof logging
yeah but now you can say i mean hey you
you implemented the verification tool
and you implemented the proof checker
uh so from the same person so are we
really sure that the circuit is not
really really really correct
and then i can also say uh yes
so because with my co-author mathias
florey
actually this was his work he
implemented
uh the proof checker plastic in the
theorem proofer
isabel which relied on
an ether-based refinement framework so
we start with the abstract specification
on the ideas
and in the final step we then got
an executable proof checker
and pasteq is contained in isabel's
archive
of formal proofs and consists of about
eight thousand lines of code and finally
for
before the break and i want to show you
uh uh
some some experiments so i'm not
so we are not the only uh ones working
uh
on that so in essence two other groups
also working on verification
of eight level integer multipliers so
the first ones
here are uh located in
university of massachusetts and the
second
group is located at the university of uh
paymen and we now
want to compare our approaches
uh to their work so from our side uh
like the community system mathematica so
our first attempt and then
our reduction ancient amulet and now the
most recent one omelette
ii uh compared to
[Music]
an abc based tool from the university of
massachusetts
and to the tool refsca from uh
in the first experiment we consider now
384
different multiplayer architecture so
simple and complex ones
all with an input with width of 64
and the time limit in this experiment is
set to
300 seconds and here you see
a cdf plot on the left so on the x-axis
we have listed here the cpu time
and on the y-axis the number of solved
instances
and what you see here is actually with
the compute algebra system we are really
only able to solve
the most simple multiplayer architecture
out of this benchmarks
and with our reduction engine amulet 1
and especially now with
amulet 2 we made now a big jump
and amulet 2 is actually able to verify
the complete
benchmark set and the second experiment
i want to show you
now we take
the simple multiplayer architecture so
the one with the
area accumulator and the ripper uh carry
add on top which i explained earlier
where we have now different input with
so between 128 and 2014
128 and 2048.
um the time limit in this experiment is
set
to a day and here we actually see that
also now mathematica here works up to
a bit with 512
and but with amulet 2
we are now able to verify also this
large benchmark so here this 2048 bit
multiplier
within an hour and this dot here so this
512 this was exactly
the multiplier for which i did the demo
earlier
yeah and with that i'm uh sorry it
brings me to the end of this
presentation
so we get now the following conclusions
so we can decide whether circuit is
correct because yes
we have tested some cases uh if you want
to know whether the circuit is really
correct
we apply formal verification uh for
answering is the
circuit really really correct i can say
yes because we generated and checked the
proof certificate
and for really really really correct uh
i can say yes because
we used a verified proof checker
and with that i want to conclude the
first part
thank you daniela so on behalf on all
the listeners i'll do my
private diplomas which i'm sure people
are
joining uh questions to daniela
there are two questions in q a can you
see it we should really yes i can see it
so the
first one by victor uh is if the circuit
is incorrect can the non-zero remainder
at the end help to pinpoint
where it's gone wrong um so there's also
some
research done by other groups
where they either want to locate the
error
and it's um
not directly possible to say
like at which part of the gate uh
directly where which gate is at the
wrong gate
but what it's possible because you can
see it from the
um like from the coefficients of the
remainder
you can uh pinpoint
the the the cone of influence from the
output bit so you
kind of
what to say it's so you can narrow it
down to where the error might happen but
as far as i know it's so far it was
there's
no result that you can really directly
pinpoint uh
where it's gone wrong
i hope this answers your question
but it helps you to like as you did in
your example you
generated an error so so like for
purposes of debugging you you get an
looking at these polynomials you
generated an input that was wrong
namely something that actually made this
remainder evaluate to not zero was then
like something that clearly the circuit
got wrong is that right
yes yes and i think the way it's done
um to to pinpoint the errors is like to
to test actually
several cases and then kind of build the
intersection and detect which gates
are
like always deliver the wrong results so
that you can see
where it's gone wrong
so then there's another question by mina
so if the aig
is a formula that is if it has the
structure of a tree
and only inputs are replicated would the
verification be easier
how would that be explained from the
algebraic viewpoint in practical terms
degree number of monomials in theory
this would be verifying nc1 as opposed
to verifying p
the replication of inputs already seems
to make things
really hard
boom we have to say i don't really have
an answer to that right now
i guess one stupid answer is if i i
wonder if it would ever be a tree
right that somehow my feeling would be
that you always get
some kind of evil looking dog
it's an interesting computation
but i don't know armin
paul any comments
you sure so so as column is pointing out
so the aip
is is a deck
that's true yeah but that dax could
still be tree like i think that was mina
is asking about
like we could we could be lucky so that
somehow
that so that every partial
result computed by the aig circuit is
used for only one input
yeah and then i mean as army points out
you can turn the eighteen to
creep a kind of extended resolution
but then the question i mean i guessed
and then you would
add quite a lot of overheads to
[Music]
to build it into a tree and don't think
that it makes the verification
yes i guess then the verification would
be hard because
i mean what we rely on this in this
verification step
is on this cancellation of
uh of monomials with equal
which share the variables and then when
you
add further variables
then i don't think that this
cancellation immediately happens and
then i guess
um that the verification
remains too hard because because the the
phenomenals grow too much
that's that's kind of my my intuition
about it
so since i'm not sure if the chat is
visible for people
looking at the recording of this i'm
reading out that paul is commenting that
converting every output into a separate
tree
would blow up to a large tree an array
multiplier
would become exponential size
yes so and this
actually also
uh relates to massimo's question in the
chat because the national
approach would be to use the polynomial
field
f2 because yeah obviously this would
reduce the coefficients and would
reduce the degree of the gates
but the issue is that we need to write
down the specification and uh
for f2 so let me jump back
somewhere where i have the specification
there it is so if we encode another
specification
in um f2 so
there is no way to to uh
write it down in a nice way so at least
not known to me
and then we actually end up that we
convert
um have a specification for each
single output bit and that's uh has
exponential size
so that's because the spec
as muslim is pointing out the
specification is natural
uh um over the integers um
but uh not uh over uh
f2 or chief too
other questions comments
um there's one in the question answer
could you use the chinese remainder
theorem to do this modulo p
for a bunch of primes p whose product is
larger than the largest possible
coefficient that would also allow
parallelism suggests victor
[Music]
so what what i did not show today but
what we actually do is that we
um do a modular computation
but not a module a bunch of of primes
but we have um so when we have here the
specification
going up to to two n uh
minus one that uh
we calculate modulu uh two to the power
two n
so that when we encounter
uh monomials with coefficient that are
larger than actually the largest
coefficient
in the specification then we reduce
a model that that coefficient
and this helps for certain uh
multiplier architectures and with that
we are also actually
uh able to verify truncated multipliers
so where we cut
off the most significant output bits
so it's an interesting question what
would happen to the
verification step if you have to certify
that chinese remaindering in proof
system also i guess
yes so alexander
is asking i'm probably missing something
but are there any lower bounds for the
technique
for some formalization of the approach
i don't think
that there exists really like
shown lower bounds for this technique
so at least i'm not aware of
these of results on that
so i don't know which people can unmute
or not
in paul is paul beam is a good person to
to comment on this i think that but the
point this was conjecture to be
for this for for cdc and solar this was
conjectured to be
hard i mean it is hard in practice and
maybe there's a resolution lower bound
and then
paul beam and vincent blue actually
provided
polynomial size resolution proofs even
in
regular resolution so a restricted form
of resolution
however the polynomials are a bit too
large for this to actually fly in
practice
firstly and secondly my understanding is
that
actual real-world sat solvers stubbornly
refuse to find these refutations even
when you try to give them fairly heavy
hints what they should do
so since already resolution can do
pretty well it's
hard to see
what one could do but but one
interesting question i mean if you're
looking at
essentially what so my understanding of
this is that essentially we're doing
polynomial calculus over the field of
rationals and one thing you could ask
that i think theoreticians have not been
asking is how different reduction orders
would affect things because when you're
doing polynomial calculus lower bound
on the theory side we usually do a
degree respecting order
what rasboro calls an admissible order
because we want degree lower bounds and
these we can then leverage to get size
lower bonds
here you have some kind of lexicographic
order that actually does not respect
degree
um and it could be interesting to see if
you could get
for instance separation results between
somehow polynomial calculus which has to
respect
say lexicographic order or degree lex or
like questions like that might be
interesting
to
to do yes but but there i think like
as you say i mean if you do relax then
you need to pay attention that you don't
lose this this nice property what we
have that we simply write down the
gregor basis by
writing down the the gate polynomials
because i think if you do the degree
lexicographic ordering for example then
um and i don't think then you can write
down the grading basis so easily and
then you
would need to do some gryphon basis
computation
and i don't think that's
that's i think that then it gets rather
complicated again
so just a just a comment about the
relationship
with cdcl and the question about whether
this
method does better in principle this
method
is um you know on simple multipliers
is something like uh quadratic
in the the bit width roughly because
um but uh the best upper bounds
we have for resolution are
you know much higher polynomial powers
into the fifth and to the sixth
and in practice the solvers are even
with super hints or a factor of n words
so they're just
not it's it's it's not clear it's a
theoretical barrier
uh doing better but
but the difference in the polynomial is
that there really isn't going to be a
way for cdcl solvers
to match the kinds of uh low degree
polynomials that you get out of
out of these algebraic techniques
so i think this comment is is related to
what other this
is writing in the chat so is there any
intuition that explains why multipliers
are easy
for the algebraic technique when they're
hard for cdcl are there more examples
where this method is better
than cdclb on the multipliers
i don't know paul do you want to comment
or dummy alarm
one one other comment the the resolution
has uh you know good uh
theory i don't think there's there
really aren't lower bounds by the way
uh for that are are
larger than just the sizes of the
multipliers
for solving these problems so they're
these algebraic methods seem to be
very efficient
i don't know if it's an answer but one
one i mean
one observation is that the algebraic
framework allows you to route
write down the specification in a very
nice way as this exponential sum
what we have on the slide now it's not
at all
clear how to write this sort of in a
clean way as a
as a cnf formula that is obviously
correct i don't know if that's a
good answer but that's like some
intuition
certainly being able to use these large
coefficients is
something that cnf can't can't really do
well at all
massimo is saying sorry for spamming
but i got curious well i guess this is
not spamming in the incremental layered
approach
is it a good idea at each step to
extract equations for the next
computations
even if they violate the grammar based
property
so they're not sure actually what you
mean
with um to extract equations
for for next computations
i think i will just try to mute myself
uh
now i was in the layer approach you you
do one layer
and you get some polynomial equations
right and then you
do the other layer and of course uh you
you can use the the you i mean that's
the point of the linear approach i guess
you use the the equation that you get
from the previous layer into the next
layer right
yes and but this la this this
this equation may not be they may not
fit well with the idea that you want to
keep
a grabner base basis
and still they may be uh
like uh they may be good to
uh to keep around right
yes ma'am so so what what we do is in
this algorithm so uh
we we start here um at
the most significant bit and then as you
said so we reduced by one slice and then
we
we receive here so this remainder
of one slice uh which then
uh we then use in the next smaller slice
again so we always add uh them um
up to the specification of the next
smaller slice
however the the gates itself which are
in the in the slices they always
form a graven bases because also if we
make here the cuts we still have this uh
property uh with um
that uh with the ordering so we always
uh keep the gribner bases properly
okay i think i i think i have a like
that understanding of the process it was
a little bit different
uh which was a different idea that you
may verify
maybe just uh like a prefix of the
output
and uh during this verification process
you
of course get a lot of uh partial
partial uh uh which i eq
sorry some equations that that relate to
that part of the circuit
and then you bring this equation to the
other layers
and you sort of verify prefix of the
output one by one but in the different
direction actually
so i i think i i understood differently
the
the process i'm sorry no i mean
actually uh so so
um i hope now i'm getting right into
your thing is so so you would uh like
move
uh the gate like the the constraints
between the layers and and use them
early in the in the verification process
because this might help
to to to uh
[Music]
to cut down the size of the polynomials
and then that's that's actually possible
because this uh
allows us the grammar basis argument to
do so when we have our gravity basis
and no matter what computations during
pre-processing we do in our previous
basis we still have a privilege basis
we are free to choose the reduction
ordering
we just need to make sure that in the
end that we
reduced by all uh polynomials that were
possible but we could definitely
do so and put
polynomials to two different slices if
that's necessary and helps to to keep
to reduce the number of the monomials
but i have to say i haven't seen that
too much
in in practice that it really would help
to move
gates between
the slices
i think it's getting time to wrap this
up i'll try to summarize there's a lot
of things happening in the chat and
there's one final question in the q a so
in the chat
we have one more comment uh regarding
the intuition why algebra is helpful
it might be related rights are men to
being able to capture the carry
polynomials
there's more than one bit of information
going from one column to the next
um and then there's a question bio that
follow up is there an illustrative
example that is easy for cdcl but hard
for the algebraic approach
and the answer is kind of no and maybe
kind of yes it's no in the sense that if
you would allow
formal variables for negative literals
also known as dual variables or twin
variables and it's not so hard to see
that this algebraic reasoning we've seen
now can
at the theoretical level can simulate
efficiently anything that
resolution can do but it's exponentially
stronger
so if there's something that's easy for
cdcl
in theory but hard for the algebra
approach it would have to be
because of a kind of blow up issue
because you get monomials
like where you would like to have
negative literals but you don't and so
things blow up
and as armin is noting then in the chat
so this other equivalence
checking that daniella had is in
practice at least easy for cdcl
but in practice doesn't seem to work
with your
algebraic approach although i guess we
don't have a lower bound for that
actually that's another like
possible question at the intersection of
theorem practice maybe if you could
quantify
it this step is somehow hard if you if
you have to encounter a polynomial blow
up
i guess it is correct to say that just
in practice it doesn't fly
yes and you can and you can observe that
the polynomial blow up is what seems to
kill it
yes because i think you mean i think the
reason are these
as i showed the sequences of or gates
which uh
led to this explosion in this in this
algebraic approach
but they can be fairly
easily dealt with i deal with in the
ctcl servers
and then the final question in the q a
it was mentioned that you're mentioning
is quadratic in the bit size is that
mostly because the specification is
quadratic in size if so
what would happen if you use the
karatsuba multiplier which is only n to
the a
where a is the logarithm base two
of three um
[Music]
so with the quadratic in the pizzas yes
i mean
we we already introduced the um
uh that oops
uh with the quadratic size of
the of the specification as you pointed
out correctly
um what would happen
if you use a card super multiplier
i mean our um approach
also always relies on this like on this
internal cancellations
because parts of the multipliers are
always just this full edges
which have this linear shape so that's
why the um
the quadratic uh uh
size comes actually from from from the
specification
and i don't know if the character
multipliers also internally
built with only that so i don't know
if like if the specification of the
current super multiplier is
small but during the verification uh
then the because of the shape
or the structure of the multiplier
this gets out so i actually have to say
i have never tried these these cards
were multipliers before
so i'm not sure i'm thinking that this
is more like or this is
this i should know this better but i
guess i don't so i'll just speak but
uh the i think these are our this is the
algorithm for multiplying like really
large integers efficiently so i guess
you wouldn't see that like
the name of the game here is i guess we
don't get to choose the circuit design
like someone
gives us a nifty circuit design and
wants us to verify this somehow right
and that's
why we're sort of we have to work with
what we're given
okay one very very final question from
paul beam what about wallace tree
is that the same size as the circuit
in terms of performance for the
specification i guess yes
yes so also for wallace trees um
uh we did not see uh
also there i think we have we have this
quadratic uh
size
so they are definitely uh easy for for
the algebraic approach
to verify because also the wallace trees
uh
um like they are build out the full and
half adders but only they are arranged
like in a different
pattern
so i guess so with this i think we
should wrap it up so
the problem is now that we're almost out
of also the second hour because you gave
a far too interesting talk daniella
generating far too interesting questions
or maybe the chair was doing a poor job
in moderating and cutting things off
earlier
but then again having these kind of
questions and discussions
is i guess part of what this is all
about i suggested following that we take
a
10 minute break and then let's just
reconvene and see
if there's anyone having energy for
talking more or if we should just
discuss
whether we should talk more at some
other times does that sound like a plan
it's fine for me so okay let's but then
we're we're uh
pausing now and uh reconvening let's say
1925 european time so that should be
what like 10 35 pacific
whatever in 10 minutes from now see you
in a bit
for those of us who wish to recommit
so i guess we're starting to come back
from the
break
and there are still some valiant souls
around
what do you say what should we do what
what's on the menu
i'm i'm not entirely sure how to
do this like if we should just uh do
like a
the second technical talk now if people
are up for this or
if the speaker is up for this i have no
idea right
this is i mean um
what i mean i didn't actually expect
that it's already like
like 7 25 here um
so i prepared a kind of a
short dish talk about how we do the
proof vlogging
uh in in our tools but i guess i mean
this also takes i don't know
15 20 minutes around
so i don't know if you should do that
right now or if you just
do let's ask the first one would it be
an option from the speaker side let's
start with that i think that's the most
important question
like listeners is the second concern but
if we don't have a speaker then it will
be really hard
you mean i'm still there you're still
there okay
so what do people say so let's should we
like take a shower
of hands or something people who want to
hear like uh
20-ish minute talk if you have if you
see on the participant panel
like you can raise your hand
do you know how to raise your hand if
like if i click on the participant list
then
i at the bottom i have some choices like
mute me
or invite to raise my hand
and i'd like to see some so if you're
raising your hand now then you're voting
for having a talk
and there are some hands going up in the
air
two for micro
[Music]
so what do we do okay so if we take all
our hands
down and then we take okay so please
take your hands down and then we take a
quick vote just people who say no this
is fascinating but there's no way i can
listen now better to reschedule some
other time
with people who voted before take their
hands down and now hands up for people
who want us to find another solution
blank votes are also okay i'm just
trying to
so people who want to reschedule to some
other time this is fascinating but i
just can't attend right now
jakob why didn't you share this more
properly
okay i think we have a majority for
actually running the talk so let's do a
20-ish minute or whatever
i'm a little bit little bit hesitant
about your time estimates
daniella regarding your first hour talk
you know but let's see how we do this
let's keep going yeah no no no i i try
so
um we are doing a talk on i guess
verification for verifying the
verification
yes so that's
where we are so this was my slide to
meaning that uh uh whether we can trust
uh the verification process so we want
to generate machine checkable proofs
and yeah i will skip now
this repetition part so we already saved
two slides
so we are now concerned uh here with
a proof system which allows us to reason
um
over algebraic uh uh
the polynomial equations and
uh there is this uh i guess
proof complexity well-known uh algebraic
proof system
called the polynomial calculus
which allows us to derive whether
which allows us to write down whether a
polynomial is contained
in uh an ideal uh
generated uh by a set of polynomials so
we have
uh given here a set of polynomials three
in the set of polynomial
polynomial f and then in the polynomial
calculus
approved to see whether f is contained
in the ideal
generated by g is a sequence of uh
proof rules uh where each proof rule
is either the boolean axiom which says
that we
the possible values are only one or zero
um or by the addition and the
multiplication rule
and this these uh additional
multiplication will
actually monitor um
the properties um of the ideal which we
had previously so that the ideal
is closed under addition uh or by
multiplication
by any other polynomial
and when we taken our an example so
we have here a small circuit consisting
of an inverter so b
is the negation of a and then c
uh is the conjunction of a and b so c is
actually in fact uh computes a and not a
so that's why the output is uh
always zero so we have here um our
specification
c is equal to zero and that's what we
want
to show that from these two gate
constraints we can derive that c is
always equal to zero
and here you see the corresponding proof
tree
uh or respectively here uh the proof
sequence as it would be written down in
the polynomial calculus
and what you see here is that
now is the question whether um
or how easy uh or how we can now
check this proof and you see that's not
easy to able
because like seeing this polynomial
it's hard for us to decide how this
um uh polynomial
was actually uh derived whether it was
the addition rule or the multiplication
rule
uh that uh was used so
the polynomial calculus is actually
quite hard to check
so that's why we introduced a different
like a more concrete approved
format so we translated the polynomial
calculus
uh into the practical algebraic calculus
as we
um call it where
the given gate and boolean value
polynomials serve
as axioms and then we have instances of
the additional multiplication rule
to derive the polynomials
yes so that's the syntax i will jump
over that
uh because it's any way way easier to
see here
on our previous example
so we have here the given polynomials
and then we have here now the sequence
of
the multiplication and the addition
rules
and you see that here for the
multiplication rule for example
uh we first write down the operator and
then the two polynomials
which were used in a multiplication step
to derive the conclusion
and for proof checking we then simply
traverse
over each proof rule and for each
proof rule we check whether we
know already the indices so uh
the antecedents so for multiplication we
only need
to check this for the first polynomial
and in this case we see the third the
the
polynomial yes we know it because it's
one of the given polynomial
and the second property uh we need to
check for each proof
is that the conclusion is actually
correct so in this case we multiply
these two together and then get then
the conclusion polynomial
and that's uh what we do
for for proof checking and you see with
this new format it's uh
actually rather easy to do so
so as i said all of our approval
contains four components the operator
the two antecedents
and then the conclusion where the
operator is either a plus
or multiplication and then we check the
connection property namely that we
already know the antecedents
for addition we need to check this for
both
[Music]
antecedents for multiplication only for
the first one because that's
how the ideal is defined and then we
check the inference property
namely the correctness of each profile
so that really the
conclusion is uh
can be derived from the antecedents
using the given operator
and furthermore we also make
a target check so that at least one
of the conclusion polynomials in the
proof is equal to
the target which we want to have for
example the specification
of the multiplier circuit
yeah and that's
the pseudo code for the proof checking
algorithm which i just
explained but i also will jump over that
and then i'll briefly want to mention
how
we generate this approves in our tool
so the given multiplier the given
polynomials
are obviously all the eight polynomials
and the boolean value constraints which
we derive
during modeling so we simply uh print
them
so down while modeling and this will
then act as our
initial constraint set of uh
the proof and then for the actual
proof generation we need to distinguish
whether we are
in the pre-processing so in the variable
elimination step
or in the spec reduction step
uh yeah in the pre-processing step
as that we have the given grammar basis
we want to derive a simplified grammar
basis
by always taking two polynomials
from the grammar basis then do this
reduction step
uh the remainder will then be added to
the grammar basis and
both previous elements from the gravity
basis
will be thrown out so that's the
reduction step
we do here in the pre-processing
and in the spec reduction we have our
ordered partner basis
we have our specification and
yeah now we want to determine whether
specification is containing the ideal
generated by the grouper basis
initially we set our remainder to the
specification and then we always
do this reduction steps uh
until uh like we reversed once
through the complete grammar basis and
check whether the result is
zero so also here we always do the same
reduction steps as here in the
pre-processing
um the difference here is that in
pre-processing both polynomials of the
reduction step so both here the p
and q are already contained in the
grammar basis so there are elements from
there
uh while in the specif aspect reduction
um the specification so the polynomial
which is reduced by the urban basis
is not con is not known to us because we
want to show it that it's
uh contained in the idea so over here
the second element uh is contained in
um the grammar basis and that's what
we need to keep in mind
when we write down the proof rules
but first to the actual reduction step
when we have
p and q and we want to get the remainder
of reducing
p by q then we do the following steps so
at first
we divide calculate the quotient of
dividing p
uh by the leading term of q
then we do a multiplication step in an
addition step
and i better show this quickly on an
example because then it's easier to see
what is going on in this algorithm
and for that i take again the
pre-processing example which
i showed before the talk where we have
our ideal
and we reduce
the first polynomial here by the second
polynomial in order to eliminate the y
so the first polynomial acts now is the
p in the reduction step
second is the q in the reduction
algorithm
and at first we calculate
so we divide p by
uh by so this is the first polynomial
uh by y and write down the the quotient
so we see here the only monomials are
containing y's here
plus x y and here minus y uh
we remove the y so get here x minus one
we multiplied this quotient now
by our polynomial q to get
here this result and add it to
p to get the final result
and this polynomial will then be added
to the grimnar basis and the other two
will
be removed and when you compare to the
previous slide you see that
that exactly is the elimination content
idea ideal
as we had it uh previously
uh yeah so that's where we want to write
down now the proof steps
and here are the only uh
polynomial operations uh that uh that
are done like with
our given set of formula basis so that's
where
we need to write down the proof steps so
since we have a multiplication and then
addition operation we print here
a multiply rule and an addition rule
and as i said for the preprocessing step
this is
really fine because
both polynomials p and q are
contained in the grouping basis so
proof checking is fine here
but in the specification reduction
the first polynomial is not containing
the ideal so that's where we run into
trouble here
in the addition rule because if we would
print it down like that
the proof checking algorithm would say
is hey this polynomial p
uh which is the specification is not
known to me
um that's an error there so instead what
we do is we kind of have
printing flags so if in the
pre-processing step
then we print this addition rule
otherwise
we collect the factors on
so that the
the results here of multiplying the
quotient
times the g on the stack
uh we keep this stack and when we are
done with the specification reduction
then at the end we print eight rules
for uh this stick
so let's get let me go a little bit into
detail here
why this works daniella so there's a
question also i don't know if you want
to take an hour later but
paul asks in the dag version isn't this
just always substitution
do you have simpler code for that case
this reduction when when the leading
terms are always
this output gate of the circuit i think
um no i mean actually we
we uh always do
here this uh
division by the leading term
multiplication and
addition step
so so what would you mean with a simpler
code i mean actually i mean
what this boils down to is that we
always substitute the tail of
of of q uh
into to all currencies of the leading
term
for q um
but so far
so so that's that's really hard these
steps uh
as we uh um
uh execute them and also that's how we
write down uh the
the proof logging steps always this
multiplication and
the addition rule
i hope this answers your question
okay thanks good um
yeah so that's that's uh well we were
so because what happens in this spec
reduction is that
uh like in the first step um
this r is equal to the specification um
f
and then we always kind of plug in here
the steps which we did in in the
reduction algorithm
until we get here our final remainder
the rn plus one which is equal to zero
and along that we can we always kept
here these
these uh uh
results of the multiplication steps uh
on a stick and when we now unfold here
this this reduction
we actually see that we can write down
this rm
plus what as f plus the sum
of all these elements on the stack when
other way
in other words that f is equal to minus
one times uh
all the elements on the stacks and
so and that's exactly kind of what we
then write down here with a sequence of
addition rules
and um do one negation step
uh to reach the final specification
so that's how we write down uh the
proofs
uh in the amulet
yeah and then quickly finally um
we worked a bit on on the proof format
so this was our initial format
where we really wrote down a
multiplication and an addition rule uh
also for all the the boolean axioms
and we recently modified this
proof format to allow us more as a
shorter and more concise proof so the
first
step was is that we handle now the the
boolean variables implicitly
so we remove them from the given set of
polynomials and also now in the proof
rules we always calculate again that a
times a for example here
is equal to a instead of
a squared so that's where we had these
rules
uh the second optimization is
because you see here that we write down
here this conclusion polynomials minus a
times b
again here is an antecedent so we
write down polynomials multiple times so
instead we now
introduce indices so we label also all
the given polynomials and then
introduce a label for each holes because
this allows us tend to address
the antecedents in approvals to
re reduce the size of each room
and the third thing which we did is
that we added a deletion rule uh because
after checking each
proofroom the conclusion polynomial
would then be added to the constraint
sets with each proof rule our constraint
set grows and grows and growth
uh but sometimes it happens that you
don't need a proof rule anymore
um in the future and maybe during proof
checking you already notice
so you can write down a deletion rule to
remove it from the constraint set
um to keep the size of the constraint
that small
this all helps to reduce
the size and the memory usage of our
proof checker
and yes that's where i will stop
right now so that's what i wanted to uh
talk about proof checking and proof
logging
for our application so a question is
having
having labels or line numbers
for the constraints is that mainly to
bring the proof size down and if so like
how important is it
uh yes so it brings the proof size down
because we now write down conclusion
polynomials uh only
once and
this together with uh
hiding kind of this boolean value
constraints
in the proof uh gave us kind of an order
of magnitude
a short proof and this also reduced the
proof checking time because quite a lot
of the proof checking time actually
comes from passing proofs
yes and yes massimo is pointing out you
don't need to look for a polynomial in
the database
you uh access the database with the
corresponding index and then you see
whether uh yeah
whether the proof rule is is uh then
uh correct yeah yes though i mean if you
wanted i guess you could do some hashing
or something there
so it's not clear to me that that's like
the killer
is it i i would have guessed that it's
more about proof size
but i don't know if that guess is
correct uh
yes i mean so that's what what we did in
our all the proof formats
there we did the hashing so in our polls
all the proof uh format
there when we explicitly write written
down the polynomials
uh then you could only introduce a
polynomial
once but now with this indices we still
have the effect
that now you can introduce or add a
polynomial
uh to the same to the constraints set
multiple times using different indices
so now we have
kind of the notation from uh like sets
to to to multisets i'm also a little bit
curious about this
deletion oh sorry i interrupted you
no so so i think when
when you're doing for cdcl solvers then
deletion is is important
for for proof verification performance
because
you're going to do a lot of reverse unit
propagation
and that of course can scale linearly in
the size of the database so
so bringing the database size down is
important but here you're
i think you're only doing like explicit
derivations so
so it's still like memory usage still
becomes an issue
uh not time wise but but space wise
there yes so especially for
for this really large multipliers which
we had with this 2048
i was um
uh like able to to bring our cluster to
to its limits when we don't do the
deletion rule
wow so that's related to i think a
question by paul that is appearing in
the chat how large do the working sets
and the constraints you deal with get
um
so you don't have a number right now but
it's it's
more than millions so for this large
benchmarks it's more
uh than millions because you see already
the one i showed you you have more than
two million uh
so for this 512 mil bit multiplier you
have more than
2 million nodes so for each of the nodes
you already write down one gate
constraints
and
[Music]
so we where do we go from here what are
challenges that you currently cannot do
or like you or the problem is sold now
we should move on and do something other
than circuit verification because we
know how to do this
i mean that that would be nice so no but
the the we are at this point right now
that
we can verify this this
is especially for the multipliers uh
that we can verify the
the the
different architectures as as they are
right now so like that you really design
okay i want to make this architecture
uh like swallow tree and uh the carrie
look ahead header
so that i think that's that's there we
are pretty safe right now
but in practice uh then
the hardware developed but they use some
synthesis and optimizations to reduce
again the number of of of the the gates
uh and also then to so to optimize the
circuits
and these uh optimization techniques
they kind of destroyed
the the still
somewhat regular architecture of this
multipliers
and um so
that's where kind of the challenge is
right now
because these
the destruction of the
architecture leads to that the
the polynomials grow again
because we don't have these nice
patterns that we have these internal
cancellations
and that's where
uh yeah we're kind of stuck right or
wherever we are
still work needs to be done
and this techniques you had for for
slicing
and dicing the circuits and eliminating
those
somehow don't don't work as well for
this optimized
designs yeah because somehow this this
uh techniques they also rely on
on on the boundaries so that uh for
example we have this nice clear cut
between the final stage adder and the
accumulation step to do this adder
substitution
and when the gates are optimized these
clear boundaries
do not exist anymore so for example then
my tool does not know where this clear
cut
needs to be done whether it
actually it's even unclear if it still
exists
so uh that's where i think
we we need to think further on how to
handle these
these architectures so
so would you verify these architectures
directly or is it conceivable that you
could do
things like equivalence verification
like you start with a stupid
circuit before optimization and you know
that it's correct and then i provide
proof step by step that
yes this optimization step did not
change the functionality of the circuit
yes i mean that's also kind of uh what
what is done in practice so where you
start with this regular multiplier
or just regular circuit and then
step by step verify the correctness of
the optimization but i mean in practice
this this needs to be done manually and
i think that's also kind of
what what we can do is that we verify
the equivalence of these these uh
multipliers
uh so like as you said this step wise
so that we do not directly jump into
this really complicated super optimized
but verify each optimization step
this could could be a possibility
so any other questions
so so one observation that might be
worth
making is that on the in the theory side
you can discuss
what the how to measure proof size for
polynomial calculus
proofs and in fact you get very
different proof systems depending on how
you
represent the polynomials you can
represent the polynomials as
linear combinations of monomials and
that's like classic polynomial calculus
or you can say well
i would prefer to write down my
polynomials in more efficient ways
some kind of binary decision diagrams or
maybe as general circuits
and then it becomes much much much
harder to prove
lower bounds so then actually pretty
soon we get into settings where we
cannot
prove any non-trivial lower bounds but
then an observation is that
here for what you're doing here this
seemingly naive model where a polynomial
is a linear combination of monomials is
in fact
like that is what a polynomial is for
you is that true
yes so that so that lower bounds in this
setting that theoreticians would come up
with
are potentially like relevant in that
sense in that they correspond to a
computational model that would exist
there out in the real world
or are you like representing your
polynomials in smarter ways
i mean we really represent them as as
sequences
of of uh monomials
so we do not have like internal
likelihood that is this decision
diagrams or something like that so
we really have it as uh sequences
of of uh monomials
and um yeah for the terms we use
a hash table so we shared the the terms
internally
[Music]
but for representing the problems they
are really just the sequence of
monomials
more questions comments
before we say that daniela has worked
hard enough for us
sorry for taking so long
i think we all enjoyed it
i hope so otherwise we wouldn't have
stuck around
[Music]
okay so i think we yeah
so let's that maybe we're calling it
today
thank you so much again daniela for this
talk
and uh
and then i'm thinking about for next
week
i think we're having a deep dive into
pseudo boolean solving
so don't miss that 5 30 european time
next tuesday okay thank you so much
that's it for today
you